[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to today's broadcast on oncoming
precision assay on the iron torrent
genexa system by varun bagai
i'm ben halen of thermal fissure
scientific and i'll be moderating
today's event
before we begin i'd like to encourage
you to engage with us
you can submit as many questions as you
want at any time you want during the
presentation
simply type them into the ask a question
box on the left and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
please welcome varem
thank you ben for the introduction hello
everyone my name is vernon begay and i'm
currently working as senior technical
project manager for thermo fisher
scientific with the analytical
validation consulting team
today we are going to discuss the
recently launched aquamine precision
assay on the iron torin genexis system
so before we get into the
oncoming precision assay i wanted to
highlight this fact that the next
generation sequencing technology has
become a very important tool for
clinical oncology research according to
the 2017 published personalized medicine
report 73 percent of the medicines in
oncology pipeline today have associated
biomarkers
which and it's quite evident that now we
need a technology that could detect
simultaneously different types of
biomarkers from a single sample and ngs
as a technology allows us to do that
so as labs across the globe started
adopting ngs technology into their
clinical workflows there were few
challenges and barriers
experienced that are highlighted below
right so the first one out of that is
that nts is too slow so it requires days
and often weeks to get the results back
once it is submitted
the second point highlighted is that ngs
is too complex so there's high level of
user expertise required to run ngs
instruments as it's not a fully
automated
asset before the launch of the genexis
instrument
and we have modular workflows requiring
multiple instruments and touch points
for running the ngs assays for example
using iron torrent gene studio system we
have about six instruments and seven
touch points with about 75 minutes hands
on time
which is
also equivalent to other technologies
like illumina and kaijan gene reader
so the next one highlighted is that ngs
is too costly so the cost of hiring and
training staff it gets added added on to
the ngs stats and also there's cost
penalty for running small batches if you
don't have enough samples currently
the last one mentioned here below is
that ngs is too limited as a technology
because you have you know tissue
requirements right if you're running an
acid with requiring higher inputs of
tissue then you will start seeing a lot
of qns failures
so a new day for pristine oncology was
observed with the launch of the iron
torrent genexis system which is the
world's first turnkey automated ngs
system that allows specimen to report in
a single day with only two user touch
points the image on the right shows the
two instruments that will be part of
this genexis system there being the iron
tauren genexis instrument the one with
the bigger size and then the smaller
instrument shown here is the genexis
purification system that launched last
month
so some of the benefits of using the
iron torrent genexis system are that it
provides single-day turnaround time for
you to and provide the results for in
from ngs with along with isc and at the
same time
it's an automated sample purification
library prep sequencing and analysis
solution
which helps increase the reproducibility
while reducing your personal costs it
allows the flexibility of economically
running few or one samples reduces the
need for batching and help us to deliver
results faster than ever before
so this system was manufactured at a
facility registered with fda and iso 13
485
and some of the research applications
for this instrument include the oncology
and inherited disease with reproductive
health and infectious diseases to come
in the future
so please note that the the integrated
workflow including the genexis
purification and the genexis instrument
will be launched with the genexis
software 6.6 update coming in next
couple of months
so the itar engine x's integrated
sequencer maximizes the flexibility
because of the fact that it now utilizes
a chip which has multiple lanes so up to
four different assets can be prepared
and sequenced simultaneously in a single
run using the iron torrent genexis
instrument
it also allows you to multiplex up to 32
libraries in a single run if you're
running a one pool assay and if you're
running a two-pole assay it will be a 16
up to 16 libraries can be prepped in a
single run
so there is two weeks on instrument chip
and raising stabilities for your
sequencing regions at the bay
the assay and throughput flexibility is
also facilitated by the strip and
multi-lane sequencing chip so you could
use one lane at a time if you have fewer
samples and if you have more than eight
samples or higher you can run the four
full lane chips
minimize consumable footprint now
require reduces the required storage
space so we had some of our reagent
cartridges redesigned so it takes less
space to store them in the -20 freezer
going into details for the genexis
instrument and the
the genexis purification system so this
system allows you to do the both the
purification and quantification starting
from a wide range of sample types
highlighted in the left so you could
start using ffpe tissue frozen tissue
bone marrow whole blood
pbl urine saliva so all of these sample
types can be extracted using the
purification system
so for an example shown here you it's a
two hour turnaround time for doing 12
ffve samples for isolating both dna and
rna and if you were starting from plasma
samples so you will you can if you're
able to extract six plasma samples
for from a single run
on the right it shows the library
preparation to the minion interpretation
time for the i'm turning to nexus gx5
chip which has 12 to 15 million reads
per lane so total of four lanes on this
chip provides about 48 to 60 million
reads
and as an example shown here if you're
running a single lane run for the
oncoming precision asset takes about 14
hours from
sample to report
and approximately about 24 to 30 hours
if you're running a full chip
the genexis software is also the
end-to-end integration so it's a fully
integrated solution enabling specimen to
report workflow so you no longer require
any additional ion reporter software or
server to do the analysis so all the
analysis happens on the genexis
instrument itself which has the software
embedded
so it's easy to use software with a new
simplified user experience that helps
minimize the learning curve in human
error
it is robust it's still based on the
variant calling accuracy that was built
for the brain calling plug-in and
installed in that iron current
instruments
it is also provides flexibility with the
option to choose between integrated
analysis on the instrument or analysis
on the ion reporter's local software
server or the iron reporter cloud so you
it allows you to choose one of the
options for doing the analysis
next i will be going over the uncommand
precision assay that was launched
specifically for use on the iron torin
genexis system and it's a new generation
solution for genomic profiling and it
aims to resolve some of the challenges
that occur with ngs discussed previously
so this assay on command precision asset
run on genexis system provides a fast
solution with a single day sample to
report turnaround
it is an easy to use
system with a fully automated two touch
points and requiring only about 15 to 30
minutes of hands-on time for setting the
both the instruments
provides cost savings as there's no
requirement to batch samples across
multiple sequencing runs so you can run
a smaller batch with a single lane
run versus a you know four lane run with
16 samples
provides tissue saving as it's built on
the our chemistry or amplicity chemistry
so it's based on the newer ampliseq hd
chemistry so with the minimum sample
input requirement
and provides maximum results from
various tissue types
so some of the highlighted features of
the oncoming precision assay on the
genexis system are highlighted below so
it's a created pan cancer content so it
covers mutations cnvs and fusion variant
types across 50 key genes
also includes the tumor suppressor
drivers and resistant variants that were
created for keeping in mind the pan
cancer content which is actionable
so it can be used for both tissue and
plasma samples so there's only the
single tests one workflow with multiple
sample types so you can use the same kit
and assay for for solid tumor or for for
for testing the
the plasma samples
it utilizes the molecular tagging
approach which is actually required for
enhanced low-level variant detection as
a key key point for liquid biopsy
testing so it utilizes the umi tags
based on ampliseq hd chemistry to get to
low levels of variant detection
and lastly we also launched the iron tor
infusion sync detection technology
which provides both sensitive and
specific target isoform detection plus
novel fusion detection from with the
exon tiling approach that will be
discussed on the later slides
as i mentioned earlier there's only one
kit with multiple applications so there
are three different workflows that can
be run using the oncoming precision
assay so you have a dna or rna only
option testing for ffpe tissue samples
so you could run up to 32 ffpe tissue
samples if you're using only dna or rna
workflow
and it also allows you to do the
simultaneously dna and rna testing for
ffe tissue samples where you know up to
16 samples can be tested including both
dna rna inputs
and lastly the same kit also allows you
to do cell free total nucleic acid
testing which is required for liquid
biopsy samples so up to 32 liquid biopsy
samples can be
prepped using the
this kit for oncoming precision assay
getting into the oncoming percent asset
content a little bit more detail so this
is this content is carefully created to
include all relevant targets of emerging
importance in precision and ecology
clinical research
so it acid covers about 50 genes with
2769 unique variants
so out of the 50 genes on this panel the
45 are covering for hot spot mutations
there are 14 genes for covering copy
number radiation and then
it also includes 19 fusion driver genes
so the span cancer span has also it kind
of keeps in mind the focus on the
non-small cell lung cancer
solid tumor indication that that's the
most biomarker rich cancer type
plus the oncoming precision assay also
includes 218 potential resistant
mutations across 22 genes
here's the pie chart that goes over the
pan cancer clinical research application
for the oncoming precision assay as
expected non-small cell lung cancer
continues to be the most biomarker rich
indication with about 25 percent of the
targets on this panel covered for
non-small cell lung cancer then you also
have the colorectal cancer breast
cancers that are you know next in line
after non-small cell lung cancer
covering about 10
of the targets
but here just highlights all the
variants all all the various solid tumor
indications that are covered as part of
the oncoming precision assay
so as i mentioned earlier the oncoming
precision assay covers 45 genes for dna
hotspots so it includes all the
important actionable genes like egfr b
raf
k ras
and the nras
along with the the idh12 plus other 35
genes for the c and v targets we have
about 14 genes and includes all the ftfr
one two three k ras meth
and cdkn2a and p10 genes
for the fusions it all includes the
previously known alk red rosman fusion
targets and also includes the newer
fusion driver genes like ftf r123
the entrax one two three and covers the
intro genetic fusions from the brav egfr
and met
gene including the met exon 14 skipping
assay
so this the bar graph uh shown on this
slide kind of goes walks us through the
50 genes covered on this oncoming
precision assay right as i mentioned
earlier this was panel was designed to
detect 2769
unique variants that includes the
hotspot mutations cnv genes and fusion
isoforms so here are some key statistics
for this panel so we have about 269 tp53
mutations which account for
approximately 90 of known recurrent
hotspots
there are 151 targeted iso forms
covering and track 123 including various
partners and breakpoints
similarly we have about 156
ftfr 123 fusion iso forms covering
various partners and breakpoints
and 89 for rent driver gene
there are three intragenetic variants
for met exon 14 skip the egfr
8 and then arv7
and there are also 218 potential
resistant mutations across 22 genes so
there are three different color schemes
shown on this graph with the blue
showing the num not the number of hot
spot mutations for a particular gene and
then the and similarly we show with the
cnb genes
and light blue for the fusion isoforms
to show as representation of how each
variant type is covered with each gene
so next i also wanted to cover the
oncoming precision assay you know genes
that are on current labels and
guidelines so as we can expect right
non-small cell lung cancer health is the
most biomarker rich indication and it
has alk b raf egfr rb2 kras met
and track one two three and red and ross
one targets which are part of the labels
and guidelines for non-small cell lung
cancer
then we have some other cancer types
for covering targets like entract123 for
pancreatic the soft tissue
and then also for colorectal cancer
there are b raf keras nres and tract one
two three targets covered so it's a very
actionable uh content pack
assay designed on the iron torrent nexus
system
next i would go over the newer fusion
zinc technology that was launched as
part of the oncoming precision assay so
before we get into fusion sync there are
two key features for optimal fusion
detection right there is one performance
of fusion detection with low input
samples and low level of transcripts
then you also would like the the fusion
technology to be able to detect normal
fusions for driver genes like that are
newer right like example n track and
fgfr
i would like to highlight that there are
many similar technologies that emphasize
about covering novel detection but they
ignore the number one which is the key
performance of detection with low input
samples
with our ampliseq hd technology you know
we cover and fusion sync detection we
address both the performance of fusion
detection with low input samples and and
low level expression plus also the now
has ability to detect novel fusions for
key driver genes
so fusion sig detection technology is a
synchronous approach that combines three
methods for sensitive specific and broad
detection of known and novel fusions
so for the neural fusions approach is
the method where you know both the
driver and partner gene and you are also
aware of the breakpoint that is involved
in this fusion event so these are you
know covered by having primers that span
across both the driver and partner gene
including the breakpoint
as part of our isoform approach
on the right side is the novel fusion
detection covering both the non-targeted
and the exon tiling imbalance approach
that was launched with this oncoming
precision assay for non-targeted fusion
detection we know the driver and the
partner gene but the break point is
unknown
but it is still covered by the panels
which are included as part of the assay
so you have amplicons covering those
diagonal partner genes and and then
unknown breakpoints
on the right is the axon tiling
imbalance approach where you only know
the driver gene but we are not aware
about the partner or the breakpoint
so this exon tiling imbalance is the
approach that is used for doing novel
fusion detection for key genes like alk
red and track one two three and ftf r123
next i would like to go into the
benefits of molecular tagging approach
which is also part of this oncoming
precision assay based on ampliseq hd
chemistry
so this is very useful for detection of
low level variants that are relevant for
doing detection for plasma samples
so this molecular tagging approach
allows for tracking and identification
of amplification from the original
molecular level versus errors that can
be introduced due to pcr and sequencing
so then these errors can be analytically
removed
using the molecular tagging approach
so this process of error removal allows
for detection of variants that can exist
at very low levels
and low level detection is necessary for
any liquid biopsy application right as
variants can be detected below one
percent allelic frequency
this is also beneficial for situations
where a tissue sample has very low tumor
content and you expect the variance to
be present at below one percent elite
frequency
next section in covering in the few
slides i will go over the performance of
oncoming precision assay
on the iron torrenting access system so
this slide talks about the performance
on ffpe controls that were tested as
part of the internal verification using
the oncoming precision assay and the
genex integrated sequences both which
were internally developed and
commercially available controls
the first control here is the internal
ffpe control which is a synthetic
control across 24 genes
and has the lily frequency around the
five percent range with plus minus two
percent standard deviation
and it has 67 smvs covered plus four
indels as part of this control so there
were 32 replicas that were tested during
internal verification
and our sensitivity for this uh control
was 99.6
with a ppv of 99.6 percent for smv and
100 for both sensitivity and ppv for in
dells
we also tested some of the commercially
available controls from horizon and
sirasiq
including both the there are the fusions
and cnvs and smbs
and we had higher than 95 sensitivity
and ppv has highlighted
so for the state of sake cnv controls
they were tested at with the plus three
copies with the five copies range and
there were 32 replicates done for these
two samples and we got it we got 100
sensitivity and ppv results
i would like to mention as a note that
this testing was performed at multiple
internal r d laboratories as part of the
product verification testing
and samples are pooled and run using
different multiplexing strategy on the
genexis instrument
next we will go over the uncommon
precision assay performance utilizing
the liquid biopsy controls so these were
again tested during internal
verification performed using the liquid
biopsy controls that are were internally
built and commercially available
so the first control again was a
synthetic control across 24 genes with a
range of lily frequency for variance
from 0.32 percent with
0.17 percent standard deviation and it
has the same 67 smb
covered as part of the panel and four
indels
so we are about close to 90
sensitivity for snv detection using this
control plus 100 ppv and for indels we
were at 100 sensitivity using 32
replicas
we also tested the internal liquid
biopsy control that was built at 1.16
full change so this is a synthetic
control that contains etfr amplification
and we did 32 replicates with a
sensitivity of 100 percent and ppv of
100
and then for the
for our liquor biopsy control covering
the fusion variants right we build a
control that contains met exon 14
skipping and
a trifusion covering three different
fusions in total rna at one percent and
32 replicates for this will run again
internally and we our sensitivity was
97.7 percent and ppv of 96.4
so here's this slide kind of goes over
the showing that the performance of the
uncharacterized ffv samples that were
successfully tested using the oncoming
precision assay so these samples were
included in our internal verification
testing
and the results actually demonstrated
successful sequencing of these different
tumor and biopsy types right so the
first example shown here in the image is
running a genexis gx5 chip with four
full length so we got about 49 million
total reads
with a with a aquarius mean a raw
accuracy of 99.04 percent and this run
had
different cancer types including bladder
cancer breast cancer with two different
samples
and also included kidney ovarian stomach
cancer plus eucharist cancer samples
at the bottom is uh showing the the
sample types of cnb and fnas right for
the lung and breast so this was a
two-lane run run that was successfully
you know used sequencing these different
tumors using fna sample input types
so some of the key genes and variant
types that were detected with cell lines
and ffpe samples as part of this
internal verification testing are
highlighted below so we as shown right
we have we covered some of the insulin
insertion and deletions for the egfr
gene
that are very relevant and important
right and it also includes the kras g12d
snv was also
tested as part of an ffpe sample then we
also
did you know c detect the er b2
amplification cnv call in one of the ffv
samples and covering the ros1 fusion
driver gene plus a p10 cnb loss that
were observed as part of the sample
study
so next i wanted to highlight the
correlation and sensitivity of mutation
calls that were observed with the
horizon ffv controlled with catalog
number hd 789
so 32 replicates of this horizon
structural multiplex control were run
during our internal verification testing
using oncoming precision assay and
genexis integrator sequencer
so this analysis includes 15 mutations
with 13 substitutions one deletion and
one insertion across 10 genes that are
detectable by the oncoming precision
assay
and these were actually verified and
present in the parental cell line within
and the mutation allele frequency range
from 3.5 to 17
the right is
kind of showing you all these 15
mutations covered across 32 replicates
so we observed an average r square value
of 92 percent
with a detection rate of or 480
out of 480 variant calls across 32
repticats were successfully observed
with a sensitivity of 100
so next i will move into performance of
the fusion controls and the ffpe samples
so there was so we had about there were
24 ffp samples that were tested with the
oncoming precision assay
using the genex and integrated sequencer
and these samples were previously tested
using fish isc and determined to be
either alk or ros one fusion positive
so our verification results showed
hundred percent concordance when using
the oncoming precision asset compared to
the other methods
so the table here highlights the 17 alk
samples which were called using aqua and
precision assay on the genexis
instrument they were also verified using
the exon tiling imbalance approach for
normal fusion detection
and it actually they showed that you
could detect all these 17 alk positive
samples using exon tiling imbalance
approach where the imbalance score and
the p value were significant enough to
be called as a present based on just the
utilizing the exon tiling
approach as part of the fusion sync
technology
and then at the bottom are the seven ros
one
samples which have which were kind of
called positive using our iso form
approach
but there you know and then the x zone
tiling approach is not applicable for
ross1 as it is not an intended target
using excel tiling imbalance capability
here are some of the examples for the
exon tiling approach using some of the
alk samples so this is our detection
using novel right excellent telling
approach and there's a bar graph shown
at the bottom for each sample that shows
you the intended breakpoint and where
you start seeing expression differences
between three prime and five prime of
the
the alk gene so the way this axon tiling
uh
imbalance works is that you you have
amplicons covering the whole exon of the
alkyne and so wherever the alka gene has
a fusion event happening and there's a
you know we start seeing higher
expression for those amplicons after the
breakpoint
so this is based on an algorithm where
you know the imbalance and the p values
are calculated for each
key driver gene and then reported as
present and absent based on the
threshold set
this approach also utilizes the baseline
for more robust calling of this exon
filing
balance
these three alkenes uh positive samples
shown here have isoform read counts
right so they're covering hip one dash
elk for the first sample with h21 x1 and
l20 they had isoform coverage with
leads calling that fusion
and then the molecular accounts for this
sample were three molecular accounts
since this asset is based on
the ampliseq hd chemistry that utilizes
the molecular tagging approach and then
at the bottom it shows that the scores
for imbalance and the p-value were
significant enough to be called as an
alt-positive
sample based on exon tiling
the next two are similar examples shown
for k5b alk and ml4 alk example from
these 17 previously tested samples
so this next again highlights some of
the exon tiling imbalance passes samples
for other key genes like fcfr3 and track
and red
so we have we ran uh you know the
control that was internally built using
the alk red and ros1 cell lines and we
we are able to have detect alk
alec imbalance positive through through
exon tiling approach and then the next
is the fcfr3 which is uh you know tested
on the rt4 cell line
again shows that we were able to detect
the fcfr3 and track one
fusion positive cell lines using this
exon tiling approach
and both alk and red
are part of the trifusion internal
control and they and it also includes a
ros one fusion but i would like to
highlight again that the ross one driver
gene is not part of the axon titling
imbalance novel detection
and elk and red are so they both were
possibly called using this approach
so along with using the cell line
controls and internal uh developed
controls we've also tested the n-track
fusion control from the serial care ffp
so this air care and track fusion
control contains 15 unique entrax
isoforms for five for in track one five
for interact two and five four three and
trixie that are covered by the oncoming
precision assay
a five percent dilution within normal
background of this control was made to
reduce the transcript levels of the
various fusion isoforms
this solution was tested with multiple
replicates using this oncoming precision
assay and the genexis integrated
sequencer the verification results
showed the ability of the acid to detect
all 15 and track fusion using the
targeted isoform designs and measuring
the read counts for each isoform
the replicate testing demonstrated high
sensitivity and specificity at five
percent dilutions above
33 fusion breeds
so on the right on the left is the 15
and entract isoforms that are part of
this control and on the right it shows
that there were 30 runs done at 5
dilution
with a sensitivity of 99.1 percent and
ppv of 100
so great data from
utilizing the commercially available and
track fusion control
but that are
that summarizes our topic of discussion
today covering the oncoming precision
assay on the iron torrent genexis system
thank you for your time and we are now
ready to take any questions that you may
have
uh hey thank you veron for that very
informative presentation um we've
received some great questions already in
the chat box so i'll just go ahead and
start with the first one i see here
the question is my lab gets multiple fna
samples
will genexus be able to obtain results
given this sample type
and the minimal nucleic acid we get from
it
thanks ben great question yes so with
our oncoming precision assay utilizing
the ampliseq sd chemistry we only
require about 20 nanograms of input for
both dna rna
so and what we have found using our
internal testing plus the doing
analytical validation for our customers
that we have you know we are able to run
these ethernet type sample types
successfully with minimal input amounts
okay well thanks vern um here's the
second question that came in it says is
genexis just released to run the
oncoming precision assay
no in fact the genexis instrument can be
utilized to run multiple different
assays that utilizes our ampliseq or mpc
hd chemistry
so we have already using our analytical
validation service we have already
validated
different assets covering
oncology and both inherited
space
okay
well another question that came in said
can you tell me more about the av
services and how they can be used to
validate other assays that can use the
amplitude chemistry
yes so our analytical validation
consulting services provides fast and
cost-effective validation of ngs-based
oncology assay and panels to clinical
testing labs that are following industry
quality standards and regulatory
guidelines
also we have another presentation right
now after this called analytical
validation of a next generation
sequencing laboratory developed test
that we would recommend you attend as i
think you will find the content in that
session informative as well
okay
great well i'm just looking at time and
as a reminder to our audience you know i
think we're out of time for questions
but if we didn't get your question today
anything that was submitted during the
on-demand period that'll be addressed by
the email address you provided at the
time of the registration
so i guess i just want to close by
saying thank you again to our speaker
varun the guy and to everyone who
participated in this presentation
we hope you enjoy the rest of the event
and be sure to check back frequently for
new content and presentations added
throughout the year
you